j'ai dit moi j'étais dans la boulangerie
pendant qu'on en fait aux vodafone
argent je sais pas tu connais kenshoo qu
est là la fuite du parking forestier
dans le parking et je vous ai laissé le
meilleur pour la fin
je suis tombé sur une perle les chéris
un mec de ouf très très nerveux
regarde
[Musique]
il est interdit de fumer dans le parti
mais non c'est aujourd'hui
donc vous voyez votre site justement il
ya parking qui fonctionne
il ya deux sicav un choix de sinar mas
et non mais ça va pas ça on dit un soin
il entend jamais rien et fait ce qu'il
veut il croit tout permis
c'est bon quoi j'avais dit à monsieur
vous allez mourir ou et pourquoi ils
crient comme ça celui ci la sorte
allô oui monsieur vous pouvez ouvrir
s'il vous plaît je ne trouve pas très
aimable
moi non plus je vais pas être aimable
monsieur karoutchi qui foirent ku
d'origine allemande ouvrir et sa petite
soeur
bonjour monsieur ya pas bonjour monsieur
a déjà très bien qui je suis
comme par hasard on se retrouve à
beaucoup pouvoir maintenant laisse moi
rire
ce s'il vous plaît qu'est ce que tu veux
l'appareil
je suis en clientèle mais bon là je
comprends ça en clientèle
la barrière d'accord mais est ce qu'on
peut se parler de minutes tu penses que
tu ne dois quand même deux minutes nous
écoute
pourquoi la disparue c'est pas le temps
c'est pas le temps c'est ma mère qui
m'attend là mais encore faire le beau
avec ta mère tu me la sortie 15 soit à
vers la garonne oui mais je sais oui
mais toi tu vas tu combien de fois rhon1
et fille de joie
bonjour service j'ai pas vraiment
service on se pose des questions sur la
machine
qu'est ce qui vole à l'autre là tu peux
lui refermer sa tronche et à la loterie
c'est pas un bug cd petitesse de qu'on
fait parce qu'aujourd'hui tu sais mais
qu on est dans un monde aujourd'hui la
machine absolument remplacer l'homme
j'étais dans la boulangerie pendantes en
fait au bouddha je sais pas tu connais
et yann choucq est le bourreau jb oui
oui
on n'a plus besoin de toi
les chouquettes jeu les verts moi j'ai
pas besoin
ce mot si la machine est en tuile comme
julie écoute moi bien mon petit gars qui
est sous le coup d'un jeu c'est pas que
tu connais tu connais jean michel
fougasse il marche est-ce que tu connais
tu connais croissance zéro balle comme
ça et
[Musique]
oui dites moi je me trouve à marboeuf là
j'ai un espèce de malades qu'il ouvre
pas les portes étaient coincés et
j'arrive pas à sortir s'il vous plaît je
suis pas il ya un cas social qui c'est
là derrière adéquiste mais lui mais
c'est qui je sais ta grand mère at you
know which makes montrer comment ils par
mois on t'a pistolet pour pour faire
sauter fou tu sais moi je te demande
juste une chose les excuses
j'en ai cherché je veux tu es s'agirait
surtout bazine d'accord je vais dire
mais si je viens c'est normal et les
vents bolt s'est donc je vais venir et
qui va me donner toi tu poche il se
passe quelque chose là vous pouvez
essayer de voir où il est gratuit
écoutez moi bien monsieur oui je vous
faire une révélation jeudi tiendra au
chic mais vous êtes qui je ne peux pas
vous le dire mais moi je peux pas sortir
là vous êtes gentil que j'ai au pass
chaotique
allô monsieur oui fait ce qu'ils vous
disent ils voudraient faire quoi par
exemple un émoi de cigares et une boîte
de tictacs et attention des bigots si je
vois deux petits taxis soit semble
toujours s'arracher pour ta gueule mais
c'est quoi la caisse qui se passe je ne
détiens d'accord pied sous les ors tu
vas dire la machine
la machine sera toujours en dessous de
la ligne en dessous ni au dessus ni sur
dessus ça comme tu veux
alerte et ça va franchement d'accord tu
tu fumes tu bois disco squad et
chez nous la ilham et tic tac
décernés aucune chance j'ai craché
dis moi que tu m'aimes
je te le dire en face où la barrière je
vais venir te voir et enfin d'accord
alors m
bon j'imagine un mois je peux tu es un
cadeau pour tourner merci à toutes les
personnes là du parking voilà du parquet
et bien sûr et ils ont tous signé en
plus autorisation mais il merci à eux
mêmes cantique des cantiques où papa et
la suite à quoi voulez encore la
surprise là il ya eu une chute bizarre
vous dire la vérité sur ces sites qu'il
a été garé sa voiture il a pris les
escaliers
non mais n'ont jamais revu et on a été
obligé d'aller le voir et de le signer
mais pour qui c'est une autorisation
vous dire s'ils avaient des idées
[Musique]